und kurz vor der sendung erreichte uns
diese aktuelle meldungen zu einem
baustellen drama in düsseldorf ist heute
ein mehrstöckiges leerstehendes haus
eingestürzt ein bauarbeiter wird seitdem
vermisst
mein kollege benjamin sack ist an der
unglücksstelle
wenn ihr ihn was ist dort konkret
passiert was sind deine neuen
information er heute mittag ungefähr
gegen halb zwei ist hinter mir dieses
gebäude eine baustelle teilweise
eingestürzt laut feuerwehr es zu drei
viertel eingestürzt das gerüst war fünf
etagen hoch das gebäude dreieinhalb zwei
arbeiter wurden verletzt einer konnte
rechtzeitig konnte relativ schnell
geborgen werden und gerettet werden und
kam in eine klinik
an den 39-jährigen kollegen fehlt
allerdings noch jede spur
liegt hier irgendwo unter diesen
riesengroßen trümmerberg die feuerwehr
seit ungefähr seit anderthalb stunden
mit mehreren höhenrettern dabei ein
gerüst abzubauen was auf die auf dem
trümmerberg jederzeit fallen könnte um
die einsatzkräfte demnächst werden hier
bis zu rap suchhunde eingesetzt nicht zu
gefährden wurde jetzt oder wird jetzt
das gerüst in mühsamer kleinarbeit stück
für stück abgebaut